Gabriela what would you advice to other
documentarians who were making a film
about something that's so emotional I
mean there's so many topics I think
fellow documentarians want to cover but
I'm sure there were times when you got
in maybe and you're like can I keep
going with this every day I mean I think
most people would yeah what would you
advice to fellow documentarian it's
gonna have to live with this film you
said you took you two years I think
you're so you know I think that as a
documentarian I think I can sort of
speak for all the documentaries I know
once you know and you've sort of learned
the truth your directive it is your
directive to tell the truth so for me
that was a tough one
because I didn't think I was gonna be
making this film I didn't think I would
be making a controversial film I think
it was I thought I was covering some
controversial topics but I didn't think
in general that I was gonna be pulling
back the curtain on something that
everybody needed to know so at some
point you just you have to strap in and
you have to believe in in your work and
you have to sort of believe that telling
the truth is ultimately a good thing so
you initially started out to do
something a little more lighthearted and
then you uncovered more stories and Dawn
story yeah I didn't start out thinking I
was gonna make the film at hand I
thought that I was going to actually not
be making this something necessarily
light-hearted I thought it was going to
be making something more philosophical
more of a sort of question about you
know why is it that we have these these
interesting relationships with you know
top predators and kind of exploring
maybe an exporter exploratory piece I
didn't expect it to be the piece that it
is so so yeah I think that's that's the
nature of documentaries that the future
is always a question mark
you